We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David Pakman.
This is a very important.
Voicemail, this is a voicemail from a Trump
supporting Cuban-American, and I want to take
this seriously.
OK, listen to what this gentleman says and
then we're going to talk about it.
Hello, Mr. Pakman, my name is one, I'm Cuban-American
and I voted for Trump, the reason I'm calling
is.
To ask the following question, and this might
help.
Ease the concerns of some of us have one of
the Democrats.
Doing to ensure or put at ease concerns of
this country steering towards communism or
socialism, like what unfortunately happened
to Cuba.
And other countries.
If.
Democrats are able to.
Show some type of effort.
Or.
Talk about.
Ways that they are trying to prevent that
from happening maybe, though, help gain more
votes from those concerned like I am.
So this is really important because the framing
of the question is completely wrong.
OK, this gentleman says I'm a Cuban-American
and I voted for Trump.
And on my Spanish language show, we've been
talking a lot about this.
What what exactly is going on?
What could be done to for Democrats to better
appeal to Cuban-American voters who often
reflexively out of anti Castro bias, are quick
to fall for claims that any old Democrat is
a socialist or a communist when they are not?
The question is the wrong one, because the
question is what, what what have Democrats
done?
What can Democrats do to convince us that
they are not really going to become make the
country socialist or communist?
Joe Biden is not a socialist or a communist.
Joe Biden has not proposed a single communist
or socialist policy.
There are no actual socialists or communists
in positions of power in the Democratic Party
in the United States.
AOC has called herself a democratic socialist
and so has Bernie.
And they are not only are they a small sliver
of the Democratic Party, they really are Social
Democrats.
They're not advocating for the socialization
of the means of production.
They are certainly not communists.
So the problem is not that Joe Biden hasn't
yet convinced us enough that he's not a socialist.
There's no evidence, there's no policy.
There's no reason to think the current Democratic
Party has any interest in making the United
States a socialist country.
The problem is too many people have been brainwashed
to think that that's the case absent any evidence
whatsoever.
And so we need to deal with this at a at a
systemic level.
Is it possible that if we better understood
socialism and communism, people wouldn't fall
for Barack Obama as a socialist?
Joe Biden's a socialist.
Is part of it an education thing?
Is part of it irresponsible Republican campaigns
that if you tell a lie enough times, it starts
to become the truth?
I don't know the answer, but when you hear
that the question is so wrong, what, what,
what what should Democrats do to convince
us they're not socialist?
What have they done to make you think they
are not a single actual socialist policy?
It's stunning and it's sad.
And listen, I am not a socialist.
I am not a communist.
I have never been in favor of the Cuban nor
Venezuelan regimes out of my own self-interest.
I would be telling you if Joe Biden was trying
to turn the United States into a Cuban or
Venezuelan socialist situation, because I
would be against that.
I wouldn't vote for that.
So out of my own views, I would be coming
to you and saying, guys, there's a risk of
socialism here.
There is no such risk.
And that's where this has gone wrong.
And you end up with folks saying, I don't
know that Biden has done enough to show me
that he's not a socialist.
Has he done anything to suggest he is?
And the answer is, of course, no.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about another retail chain
filing for bankruptcy.
We're going to talk about a very interesting
First Amendment ruling involving Voice of
America.
And you are not going to believe what is going
on with the my pillow guy and the Kenosha
shooter, Kyle Rittenhouse.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom.